So when I got to the ancestry portion, I sort of wanted to start with, you know,
where I was, my deep ancestory history, where I originated from. And
it showed that I was around, not surprisingly, 20% from the British
Islands and then the rest were from some unidentified
European countries, but about 1 percent was from
Sardinia, a little island off of Italy, which I find really fascinating.
>> Well I want to know, when you got the results back,
when 23 and me, I think they send you an email saying the
results are ready, what were you feeling as you, when you got the
results, rather the notification. what, what
were you actually feeling in the process?
>> I was feeling very overwhelmed because I knew that there
was a potential for me to find out from the relative finder
section, you know, my biological parents,
and, or biological siblings, or biological aunts,
or any relatives and information that I never had Because as you know, my
adoption was closed, and they didn't release any of that information, and I felt
always that I had reached a dead end, but this was a potential
It could potentially further my, finding my, my
biological birth parent. So I was very anxious very
overwhelmed, very nervous, like clicking through everything. I
even tried to like, go through all the other
parts of 23andMe before I got to that just so I could sort of, you know, calm
myself down. and then I clicked on the
relative finder. Okay, so you opted into the relative
finder, and you, you, you clicked on it. what did you see?
>> Well, I saw a whole host of third to fourth cousins.
quite a few from both England and Eastern
North Carolina, which was, which was where I was
born and raised. the closest though, I did find
one second cousin. It didn't come up at first,
after about a week, a week of having
the original results. evidently, this person opted it in.
Or 23 made was able to match her DNA
a little bit better, and this person showed up.
And it basically said that they were male and that they were
from North Carolina and they shared
about 0.97% of the DNA that I had.
And then in the advanced tools section of 23andMe you can look at your actual
chromosome pattern and see what bands of chromosomes
match, and there were quite a few bands which lead me to
believe that, you know, we had somewhat close, you know, DNA lineage.
>> Wow. So, did you, did you reach out to this person?
>> I did. I was sort of debating whether I would,
you know, contact them. Sort of open up the can of worms
or the pandora's box. Sort of get this new person involved in
my life. And I reached out and basically, I said my name,
age, where I was from, and that I was adopted and that I would love to know more
about their background, and after about three days, an email was sent to me for
this person, who gave me His name, how old he was and that he was from
eastern North Carolina. And he gave me a
bunch of surnames, hypothesizing his four grandparent's last names,
which is a very common name in the community
I was born and raised in. So I mean, it
sounds like you connected with somebody who is, I
mean, who the surnames, the family names you're familiar with.
>> I know. It was, it felt like a bit of a soap opera that I
was sort of, like becoming apart of, I called my adopted real parents, I called
them and you know. I told them I'm participating in this course, as
well as participating in 23and me and. They were not hesitant, they were
okay with it and when I told them a
list of names my mother pulled out all the phone
books from Eastern North Carolina because she collects those
evidently and was trying, like, this certain name that could
be in the county where she knew that three
other names were in. And she was calling my aunt,
to see if she knew this person, and so
it's just started this sort of domino thing where everybody's
trying to be Nancy Drew or the Hardy Boys
to try to figure out Who this cousin is.
I'm still debating about, you know, where to take
this, how, how, involved I should get with this person.
you know, I, I don't know how receptive this
person will be. And it's a second cousin which,
you know, isn't an aunt or an uncle. This,
you know? It's still a little far out. And so
for me to say I'm adopted. Do you know anybody that you may
be related to, who had a child put up for adoption? The likelihood
of that is still low, however, I am hopeful that, you know, maybe,
maybe they do know. I, I'm still debating about how to pursue this.
>> So overall, how would you
describe your emotions? Excited, nervous, happy, sad?
>> My emotions about this process are varied.
I'm excited and happy for the most part, and
hopeful. I think those describe how I'm feeling about this right now.
>> Would you recommend this for other people who are
adopted and are interested? Do you think that it has the
ability to Fill gaps in their knowlege or, do you think
that it's a positive experience that you recommend to other people?
>> I think it depends on the person. I think that, it depends
on where the person is an how, an their identity as being, adopted.
You know, are they, if they're interested and
curious, I think this is a perfectly legitimate
ada, avenue to pursue. I think that everyone
who does pursue this as an avenue for
trying to find biological relatives, should enter into
it with a mindset that, they may not
find anything. or they might find very distant
cousin. Because this is all dependent on other people
[COUGH]
opting to send in their DNA to the company. With that said, I think that as,
you know, genetics is coming to the forefront
of our everyday lives and our health, more
and more people are going to opt to send their DNA in to be sequenced and to
be analyzed and to be compared with other
individuals. So, I think that this is a very
hopeful enterprise for adopted individuals.